we have some good news in the fight
against the pandemic there's been a
dramatic
downturn in coronavirus cases and deaths
yesterday less than 54 000 new cases of
the
virus were reported the lowest number
since october
989 americans were reported dead the
smallest single day toll
since november 29th this comes after
months of about 200 000 new cases a day
nationwide
but experts say new variants could cause
those
numbers to spike again dr david agus
joins us now
david good morning what concerns you
most
right at this moment about these new
variants that we're seeing
you know i think we're in a lull now
because cases are going down and these
new variants are more
infectious that is it takes fewer
numbers of particles to create a
symptomatic
a person with cova-19 so as the variants
rise across the country and we're seeing
them rise across the country we're going
to have an
increase in the number of cases over the
next several weeks from these variants
and it certainly is scary
the suffering that they could cause how
significant an increase do you think
we're likely to see david
i think it's going to be real i mean we
saw it announced over the past day there
are seven new variants in the united
states
all of which have one point in common
and that's in addition to the brazil the
south africa and the united kingdom so
this virus is zigging and zagging i hope
we can zig and zag with it what do we
need to do to zig and zag with it and
try to hold it back
well it's going to be you know coming
down to vaccines so the
and our behavior right we need to double
up on the mass that's been talked about
in high risk situations and really
focus on that social distancing not let
our guard down
but the vaccines are going to be
critical i think of it this way is that
with the other strain the the first
strain of coven 19
you made an immune response to 10 points
well with these variants five
points have been lost so the absolute
number of antibodies in t
cells is lower what we do know now is
that
it's enough to protect most people from
getting really sick
and going to a hospital but if the virus
continues to change
i am certainly worried you're worried
that the
the vaccine isn't going to protect
people is that what you're saying
no question about it is that right now
they will you know every year
we send strains to the world health
organization and they determine
what goes in the flu shot over the
weekend
scientists across the globe we were all
on calls to identify
a a new database to do this for covet 19
because we know it's changing and we
have to predict whether we're going to
need a boost or
or a third shot to keep those levels of
antibodies and t cells high enough
to protect against these variants do you
think a booster is inevitable like by
the end of the year
i think either a booster or a third shot
again to keep the antibodies levels high
enough um
it is certainly inevitable my gut is
yeah it's going to be by the end of the
year
um we're starting now the clinical
trials they're going to be much smaller
the last ones were in tens of thousands
of people these will be in hundreds to
show that it's safe and makes a good
immune response
and then they'll be included like we get
a flu shot every year we're going to get
a booster
does this make it even more urgent for
people to get vaccinated david
the sooner we vaccinate the sooner we
can stop spreading this virus and
the creation of new variants yes yes and
yes we have to get vaccines
into arms as soon as possible and not
keep them in freezers for any prolonged
periods of time
dr david agus thank you so much for
being with us this morning